the jurgen experience it's like a
beautiful name isis
ellen's rough ellen is like an old
but it's a rough one now it's a rough
one now because she was running abu
ghraib in the back of her show
that's a rough one she's out there
dancing with kristen ballen in the back
there's people
that are getting up on the rack like
this it's so weird when you see
like a lot of people saying that someone
who seems so nice
is not nice at all she doesn't seem nice
but that's that people have a very poor
judge of character
she doesn't seem nice it seems forced
people that are like that all the time
it she doesn't seem nice it's very
forced
and whatever you're allowed to be a
[ __ ] right you're allowed to be a [ __ ]
you're allowed to be nasty to people
you're accomplished you're a comedian
you did the whole thing
what you're not allowed to do um is
have a guantanamo bay situation in the
back stage
of your show where everybody's walking
around afraid for their life
and it's like abu ghraib where they're
hooked up to wires and they
like yeah she's got dogs and hoods if an
intern is late they have a hood on
i don't support that that's just me yeah
yeah i'm with you yeah i mean you know i
wish she's best
she's around for too long all these
people walk away you've been famous
forever walk away like
eventually everybody they're just going
to figure it out now fallon's on an
apology door because
apology tour because of the black face
like is he well he was like he had to go
around and apologize a million times for
like
they're going to find the thing if you
don't go away
you got it you got to have a good run
and when you have a good run you step
back and you go okay
i'm still going to do my thing but like
i'm not i mean there's only a few jobs
in entertainment right right
so i think a lot of the canceled culture
[ __ ] is probably these [ __ ]
want those jobs ooh they're like how
long is this [ __ ] gonna be
dancing i can dance with hillary clinton
i could do the charleston with henry
kissinger whatever the [ __ ] she does out
there
did charles do this she does she goes
out there to the charleston she's got
war criminals
her and bush are jumping around i mean
right she was buddies with bush
she's a cia agent stephen paddock
and do not ask me for sources but steven
steven
paddock who's that he was the guy that
shot up the vegas concert that was very
tragic thing
listen to this the only guy that saw
stephen paddock alive his name is jesus
compost
he was a guard at mandalay bay he got
interviewed nowhere else you know where
he got interviewed in the beginning
ellen ellen really weird and then they
went on if you could find that clip
they went on with a weird like diagram
of how it happened and ellen's like
showing the people out
not like an emotional like how are you
feeling how are you holding up it was a
weird diagram of like and then he went
to the left and to the right
it was very strange to look what the
hell is going on
this is a daytime show which is the
paddock guy and
there's two guys the chubby guy is the
jesus guy and now
ellen is doing a doc thing of of how the
shooting happened look how she's got
like an antenna from someone's buick
that she's popped out and she's using it
as a pointer
but why the hell is this happening on
like a daytime show where she
this is weird where'd she get that
pointer i don't know she stole it off
she stole it off an intern's car why
wouldn't you just use your finger
like if that was you if it was your show
yeah dylan yeah when you just point
yeah yeah this is also a giant uh screen
behind her so they could have just put
it on that screen
so but she's using this thing i find it
very strange i don't know why wait a
minute those aren't real palm trees
no yes i know that street though i know
that block of beverly hills that she is
how weird is that i don't know why
they're doing this on a daytime talk
show let's keep it running
look at it she's dressed like colonel
sanders not colonel sanders she's just
like sergeant pepper this guy looks like
a member of her staff
what kind of outfit is she wearing i
don't know she wears those weird like
militant
lesbians that should tell uniform yeah
but that's an odd look with all those
buttons
like why do you have so many wrist
buttons it was given to her and langley
the only reason why you have that many
wrist buttons if you're looking at a
clothesline somebody yeah look at her
look at her everyone says she looks so
friendly she looks yeah she looks
friendly
she does look very military yeah she's a
militant woman
with a very expensive watch she dealt
with a lot of discrimination which
came out it was very sad but then she
you joined the cia
her house got broken into while she was
at home really yeah
yeah she got a dope place in montecito
and said and then they broke in while
she was there yeah and those people are
still being tortured to this day
probably they're still in an underground
jail yeah she's feeding them to her
staff
she's like it's okay don't worry about
it because you did good
is that the guy the survivor he's the
guy who met paddock
she's holding on to him it's odd yeah
she's allowed to do that because she's a
woman but if there was a man holding
onto a woman's arm that long
it'd be rape
be a real problem yeah that's for sure
so weird man what a strange interview
man
[Applause]